first through the hatch is denise
matviav three hours after taking off
from a spaceport in kazakhstan this team
of three russian cosmonauts made it to
the international space station or iss
first through the hatch was korsakoff
they received a warm welcome from their
american and german counterparts but
back home tensions among their
governments are mounting over russia's
invasion of ukraine we're less than 30
minutes away from u.s sanctions
targeting moscow space program have been
followed by threats from russia
the country's space agency chief
supports the war and has warned u.s
president joe biden the sanctions could
cause a crash
if you block cooperation with us he
wrote who will save the iss from an
uncontrolled de-orbit and falling on the
u.s or europe international approach the
u.s provides the iss with power and
russia's equipment maintains the correct
orbit keeping it away from space junk
nasa is downplaying the threats despite
all of that up in space
we can have a cooperation
with our russian friends our colleagues
the professional relationship between
astronauts and cosmonauts
it hasn't missed a beat
but collaboration has weakened the
european space agency said its
suspending participation in a russian
european mission to land a rover on mars
spacecraft launches have been canceled
and contracts broken over the war
it's a bit awkward the rest of the space
industry has been thrown into turmoil by
the ukraine war you know western
satellites so we're meant to go up on
russian rockets they're now stranded and
yet
at the iss it's as if nothing had
happened they say no we're we're uh
we're going to carry on as before they
kind of have to at some level because
they've got so much money invested in
this
political tensions now threaten to
further weaken years of shared
collaboration between russia the u.s and
its western allies as earth-bound
politics follows into space
katya lopez of the young al jazeera